[Music]
we had another round of citizens of Joe
Mallya question thank you
this one's from Matthew tank so hey
y'all hang you for your question saying
you I like I like your your juice it's
pretty good thing he's probably saying I
like dude I get this all the time for
God's all right tank I hate the space
program cuz I'm asking you that's cuz
you guys are adults I wasn't expecting
this so I think a lot of our members
here are in their 20s and you guys
remember during those time vaguely
ancient times long long time ago but
there was a point when you were we were
all on this path of what we're doing now
right and there was a lot of uncertainty
and so he asked share with us in more
detail on how you and others you know
sacrifice sleep and comfort to work
towards what you have today I think he's
saying not being sure if things would
work being tired and just want to give
up working so hard for an end result
that is unknown so I think what I get
from this is really we never knew if we
would be successful or if we could even
pay the bills doing what we want to do
but we all went for that and so what was
that process like for you nothing else
nothing in life is is secure nothing is
guaranteed right but what I did see all
around me was my parents hating their
[ __ ] job by going to work every day
9:00 to 5:00 and the other were making a
lot of money they were making six
figures at one point each but they
[ __ ] hated it and I looked at them
and I was like that's miserable
everyone I knew that went to college and
got a job and we're going to
nine-to-five they couldn't wait for the
weekend because that was the only news
drink and vision thing right he lived
for the time they get off work and I did
not want that to be my life I was like I
would rather be broke as [ __ ] doing what
I love to do then be making an okay
amount of money and hating everything
every single day and so I think if you
think of worst-case scenario first like
worst case scenario
I work my ass off and I'm still broke as
[ __ ] doing what I love
alright I can accept that you know and
because of the acceptance of outcome and
being like just living for the moment
and like living to work on your dream
and something that could happen and
dream building constantly I feel like it
doesn't matter because at least you're
building something you're building
something for you and it couldn't get
worse than where I was like it could
yeah you know like I'm already broke so
what like what do I lose really you got
into this really young you you came into
pursuing your own things straight from
18 like most of us we get regular jobs
and like we kind of dilly-dally back and
forth from college and but you went from
like 18 mango dilly-dally no it's really
great to filming doing [ __ ] you want to
do it's funny because I than I feel like
other the imposter syndrome hits me
right but then it's just like yeah I
mean I think I just knew what I wanted
and I was just like already wanting to
get into film and stuff like that a
young age and going to call it a like
this isn't gonna help me this isn't what
I need to even have doubt though at 19 a
12 oz of your super scared your life is
that I had to like convince my parents
oh yeah I'm moving to LA for school you
know don't you lie to them no they knew
like a while I was coming out here but
that was telling my once I get I got
much time for school and stuff but I
don't know for me it was just like the
stuff that I wanted to do I got lucky
that I knew how to do certain things and
also other people that needed it were
also people with that I could learn from
and then from there I just kept just
working and then that's where I feel
like it helped because now I just listen
to people that I trust so it sounds like
you networked first got yourself into an
area that can provide you jobs or
whatever because I think one of my
biggest like insecurities was networking
because I was like super introvert I
can't talk to people but like everyone
that I've ever wanted to work with and
like I was a huge fan of and even like
if they're like somewhere or they're
just getting constantly like harass my
fans or non-fans are coming up to them
I'll come up to him for some reason
don't be like you know what you number
let's talk let's do this and so without
being a hot groupie
you weren't thirsty you're too how did
you get in as through them
regular people yeah cuz you're really
good at that and you know a lot of
[ __ ] famous ass people yeah and I
never felt the thirst on you but I do
know that you were a mega fan yeah yeah
I mean it was just like it was normal
but I think like maybe cuz I also came
from where it was easier where like I
started working with people that are a
lot older like four or five years older
like was still young like all old
friends yeah
and just a lawsuit I meet now where
maybe I came from literally coming from
school where I was like like wells gonna
say for that guy was like dude here
you're at a young age where you're you
just went through the hardest thing that
we still don't have to go through you
have to wake up every single day at a
certain time go to school from will be
like 7:00 to like to immediately go home
do hella homework study do that stuff
for years so I'm like you're more
prepped than we are at this age because
we don't have to do that everything is
like we could do whatever but if you
could just continue that or even do a
quarter of what you're doing before like
that's like killing it I feel like my
age it's like it's now gate to the poem
or like if I don't push it I'm trying to
get lazy and laser that's where I'm
gonna start like derail II so I'm in a
unique position and I have a very simple
answer for you I am surrounded by people
who love what they do and it's not an
accident that they're successful because
if you spend most of your day doing
something that you love to do and you
like and you can turn that into a
business then you will wake up with that
zeal for what you are doing and and
you'll be passionate about what you're
working on and if anything I know people
who get miserable on vacations because
we like to work so much because we like
what we do so much tell me I'm wrong
so I edited a vlog every day of our
vacation and you loved it learned a lot
of things and you're sitting there
laughing so yeah work keishon yeah I
think you also don't have to like ignore
the moments where you're working at
something and it's not fun at the time
you know what I mean because because a
lot of times I think we do when we talk
about like these these dreams these
girls are like oh we're gonna pursue our
passions
it's me amazing all the time and it's
not necessarily the case if you have
this big goal you can still do all these
little things in which it's not gonna be
fun but if you keep in mind what it is
you want to do and where you want to be
it's still gonna be okay
I feel like the sacrifices are the
things that oh that stop a lot of people
like I broke most of my 20s I did not go
out I did not party I did I don't like
going out so I mean that worked in my
favor but like I didn't yeah I didn't
when everyone's out drinking and having
fun I was working on my dream I was
going to work during the day and then
working on my dream at night I go into
classes or I would get someone to cover
my shift so I could go audition during
the day and all of my spare time was
spent working on the craft rather than
going out and drinking and that's I
think something that people that didn't
do that and their 20s kind of regret
later if they had a dream and they
didn't use that time to work on it is
they're so sophisticated because like my
show wasn't that sophisticated as you
guys like for me it was more like there
was a set path that I was told I needed
to go down and I always just like my
whole life always felt like I didn't
really belong and like in every aspect
of it so then I do the nine-to-five
thing and then I'm completely miserable
and I'm like [ __ ] reckless with it
because the only thing I knew kind of
like you were you're like well what's
the worst-case scenario um I get kicked
out or I guess that could probably be
viewers yeah obviously um but I'm like I
think if I have money to feed myself I
think I should be fine because I didn't
I didn't have anything to really I
needed to take care of so I just secured
money and then at that point I'm like
[ __ ] it let's just let it ride and I
didn't know if it was gonna be if he was
gonna go anywhere I didn't know anything
other than this is fun yeah and I want
to do what's fun and and it was very
stressful because it's like it's still
work you're still working towards
something you're still trying to
accomplish things and that's always hard
but the type of stress that you get when
you're doing something that you love is
like it's still stress and it's still
[ __ ] up but it's like a different type
of [ __ ] like it's not a heavy would
you say you were money motivated
primarily no I wasn't at all that was
really poor okay before I had quit my
job like I was really financially safe
and I was getting quarterly bonuses and
I was like making really good money and
then I was like really [ __ ] poor I
was like negative in my account all the
[ __ ]
you you started withdrawing from your
401k just to make ends meet yeah and I
was sold for but I was so happy and I
think that's what kind of motivated the
whole thing I'm like I don't know where
I'm going but I'm having such a [ __ ]
blast that that's just that's just right
I think the social support helped all of
us in JK because if you're doing this
alone and all of your friends are going
to the movies because I've always been
good at going away friends and finding
new one yeah I have bad FOMO
well not recently but I was really bad
at that what do you mean like you wanted
to be with your friends and stuff yeah
but if you're if you're surrounded by
people who are like Steve said you're
focused on the same things and you love
what you do and you both have fun
creating together then it's kind of like
oh that's how me and Bart got closer
because we would make sketches while
everyone else wanted to just drink and
waste time well it's the law of averages
- so you become the average of the five
people that you spend the most time with
both owe income with the way that you
run your life like even the way you
start talking is like you absorb it like
exactly yeah for me it was like a
definite mixture of like all you guys
cuz then I was told like from a young
age you have to do this go to school
become a doctor or whatever and also
told like don't make your passion a
career because we're gonna hate it which
I from you that advice usually comes
from people who didn't do successful in
life that it in misery loves company -
yeah and they want their reality
confirmed I wasn't really surrounded by
like would you say about like being
surrounded by people that are doing what
they loved yeah
for me I just saw that online and I knew
that that was a possibility and then for
me I was just like hey there's there's
actors as this there's all these people
that are actually doing it I was like
why can't I and then I'll just like no
but that's what I want that's what makes
me happy so I was like okay that's um
one focus my time on I just know for me
it's like well I told my friends I'm
like hey if you want to do it just
YouTube look how online classes do
whatever do whatever you need to take to
learn but start yeah but I feel like
people are like is the enemy of here
yeah I think when people are asking this
question it's because they're not
starting or they're too in their heads
because when I hear is it gonna be worth
it is it gonna be a waste of time what
if I do all these years of work and I
never become successful
they're lining up the perfect shot to
never lineup it's perfect shot and
you're thinking too much about the
success part or the like image part of
it rather than like well and the failure
part of it really yeah or they're
thinking too much on like am I wasting
my time here you want to guarantee
there's no guarantees and I would say
look at really why you're doing it
because that sounds like you want the
freedom you want the lifestyle you want
the fame or whatever you might not be
motivated for the right reasons because
it's kind of like that grass is greener
effect right cuz I remember a lot of my
co-workers at the time when they're
seeing me film and doing all this stuff
they were like oh yeah I want to open up
a YouTube channel and just get away from
all this and I was like that just sounds
like escapism and I think sometimes
people don't realize that when you go
into work for yourself you actually work
more and you don't get a break so if you
want a thing that's like you're just
chilling 95s are great cuz you could
balance it yeah cut off your mind
afterward you have time to build
relationships and do all kinds of other
[ __ ] so if you want that freedom
sometimes a nine-to-five is better for
that lifestyle well you don't go into
doing business for yourself and doing
all this stuff if you want freedom this
is the opposite of freedom my
girlfriend's dad told me to not not
right because I'll never make it and
then I oh my god I won't be able Ellie's
a racket because he failed in LA and he
was trying to be an actor and he [ __ ]
up so don't don't even bother it's too
hard and then he's like I'm
businessperson we need to do is make a
business plan and if you can't tell your
business plan say how you're gonna make
money in all this [ __ ] then [ __ ]
scrap it and move on to something else
and that's the that is the enemy of what
we wear we all got right because every
time I filmed the video or did anything
like I never knew where the money was
coming from I never knew where it was
gonna hello how it was gonna work and my
parents would be like how does this
stuff work you post the video YouTube or
whatever and and I didn't know I didn't
know and it's okay to not know and to
admit that you don't know something and
just like I like doing this I'm just
gonna keep doing it and we'll see what
happens and but it because I like doing
it you can tell when you're watching it
so that's all it is I think you always
need like dump back people in their life
that like your friends they'll bring you
down though they'll hold you like things
like even just like they're super
it's about everything but they're like
you get that FOMO of just missing out
yeah best advice is don't take advice
from people that you don't want their
life yeah yeah that's that's the truth
hell yeah
[Music]